This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. Here on the show there's a fall tradition we love. It has nothing to do with pumpkin spice or Halloween, although we love those too. What I'm talking about is the annual announcement of the winner of the Nobel Prize in Economics. The Royal Swedish Academy of Sciences has decided to award the Sverius Riksbank Prize in Economic Sciences in Memory of Alfred Nobel to Richard H. Thaler. Richard Thaler has played an outsized role in shaping the field of behavioural economics. He also happens to be a great conversationalist. So we thought we'd revisit our 2015 conversation with him.
这里是隐藏的大脑，我是香卡·维丹塔姆。节目中有一个我们非常喜欢的秋季传统。这与南瓜香料或万圣节无关，尽管我们也喜欢这些。我说的是每年诺贝尔经济学奖得主的公布。瑞典皇家科学院决定将纪念阿尔弗雷德·诺贝尔瑞典银行经济学奖授予理查德·H·塞勒。理查德·塞勒在塑造行为经济学领域发挥了巨大作用。他碰巧也是一个非常好的对话者。所以我们觉得我们应该重温2015年与他的对话。
It's till one of our favorites. Richard Thaler's latest book is Misbehaving, the story of behavioral economics. I spoke to him before a live audience at NPR's Weekend in Washington, an event that brings together public radio supporters from across the country. I want to start by asking Richard a real softball question. Your friend, whose name is Daniel Coniman, he won the Nobel Prize in Economics some years ago, a well-famous psychologist, brilliant author, and Danny Coneman was once asked to describe Richard Thaler to a journalist, and he said that Richard's
这仍然是我们的最爱之一。理查德·塞勒的最新著作是《错误行为：行为经济学的形成》。我在NPR的“华盛顿周末”活动中在一个现场观众面前采访了他，这是一个汇集了来自全国各地的公共广播支持者的活动。我想首先问理查德一个非常简单的问题。你的朋友，他的名字叫丹尼尔·卡尼曼，他几年前获得了诺贝尔经济学奖，是一位著名的心理学家、杰出的作家，丹尼尔·卡尼曼曾被要求向一位记者描述理查德·塞勒，他说理查德的
dominant characteristic, the thing that makes him stand out, is that Richard is lazy. Can you tell me Richard, why Danny said that, and also why he insists that this was a compliment? Yeah, what's worse is a Danny is my best friend and B. He said this was my best quality. To this day Danny defends this and that he defends A and that it's true and B that it's a compliment because he says that it means I'm only willing to work on things that are important. The truth is I'm only willing to work on things that are fun and that's why I'm here today because I think we're gonna fun. I think that's exactly right. So I first started talking to Richard maybe about 10 years ago. Let me just ask you to give us a very short introduction.
主导特征，也就是让他脱颖而出的地方，是理查德很懒。你能告诉我理查德，为什么丹尼会这么说，以及为什么他坚持认为这是一个恭维吗？是的，更糟糕的是，A，丹尼是我最好的朋友，B，他说这是我最好的品质。直到今天，丹尼还在为这一点辩护，他辩护A，说这是真的，B，说这是一个恭维，因为他说这意味着我只愿意做重要的事情。事实是，我只愿意做有趣的事情，这就是为什么我今天来到这里，因为我认为我们会很开心。我想这完全正确。所以我大约在10年前开始和理查德交谈。让我先请你做一个非常简短的介绍。
What is behavior economics? And why has it made such a splash? Or why has it been so controversial over the last 15 or 20 years? How is it different than garden variety economics? You know, probably sometime in your distant past, all of you have had a class in economics. And you know that standard economics assumes that people are highly rational creatures,
什么是行为经济学？为什么它引起了这么大的轰动？或者为什么它在过去15或20年里一直如此具有争议？它与普通的经济学有什么不同？你知道，可能在你的遥远过去，你们所有人都上过经济学课程。你知道标准经济学假设人们是高度理性的生物，
capable of complex calculations, devoid of emotion, never having any self-control problems, and they're complete jerks. So I call these fictional creatures e-cons. That's short for homo-economicists, the Latin term. And I believe that for the last 50 or 60 years, economists have devoted themselves to studying fictional creatures.
能够进行复杂的计算，没有情感，从来没有任何自我控制问题，而且他们是彻头彻尾的混蛋。所以我称这些虚构的生物为“经济人”。这是“经济人”的简写，这是一个拉丁语术语。我相信在过去50或60年里，经济学家一直致力于研究虚构的生物。
They might as well be studying unicorns because there are no e-cons. Well, there are a few economists I know who are close, but basically they don't exist. And so we have very fancy models of fictional creatures. And the people I know have trouble figuring out how to divide a check if there are more than three people. Occasionally, just occasionally overeat or over drink, have trouble saving for retirement, and contrary to economic theory, some at least are willing to donate to National Public Radio, which any economist will tell you
他们可能也在研究独角兽，因为根本没有经济人。好吧，我认识一些经济学家，他们很接近，但基本上他们不存在。所以我们有非常奇特的虚构生物模型。而我认识的人如果在检查账单时超过三个人，就会觉得很难算清楚。偶尔，只是偶尔会吃得过多或喝得过多，在为退休储蓄时遇到困难，并且与经济学理论相反，至少有些人愿意向国家公共广播电台捐款，任何经济学家都会告诉你
is a completely irrational thing to do, because you can listen to it for free. So. So. So when I first started talking to Richard about 10 years ago, it was for a topic that was called mental accounting. Richard explained to me that mental accounting is something that we all do in everyday life. One of the things that I noticed is that as soon as Richard started talking, I started thinking of examples from my own life where mental accounting was playing a really, really
这是一件完全不理智的事情，因为你可以免费收听它。所以。所以。所以当我大约10年前第一次开始和理查德谈论这个话题时，它是关于一个叫做心理账户的话题。理查德向我解释说，心理账户是我们大家在日常生活中都会做的事情。我注意到的其中一件事是，理查德一开始说话，我就开始想起自己生活中的例子，在这些例子中，心理账户发挥了非常非常
big role. Let me just start by having you tell life where mental accounting was playing a really, really big role. Let me just start by having you tell us what mental accounting is, Richard. So a basic concept of economics is that money is fungible, which means that there are no labels on it. There's a video of Dustin Hoffman and Gene Hackman talking and Gene Hackman's telling this story about when they were young actors.
大的作用。让我先请你告诉我们，在生活中，心理账户发挥了非常非常大的作用。让我先请你告诉我们什么是心理账户，理查德。经济学的一个基本概念是，金钱是同质可替代的，这意味着上面没有标签。有一个视频是达斯汀·霍夫曼和吉恩·哈克曼在交谈，吉恩·哈克曼在讲述他们年轻时作为演员的故事。
Hackman goes to visit Dustin Hoffman in this little apartment in Pasadena. Dustin Hoffman has asked him to borrow some money. And then Hackman goes into his kitchen and he sees these mason jars that have labels on them and one is rent and one is utility and there was nothing in the jar labeled food. And so you don't need any money, you've got lots of money in all these jars and Hoffman says, yeah, but there's nothing in the food jar.
哈克曼去帕萨迪纳拜访达斯汀·霍夫曼的一个小公寓。达斯汀·霍夫曼向他借了一些钱。然后哈克曼走进厨房，看到这些贴着标签的罐子，一个是房租，一个是水电，而贴着食物标签的罐子里什么也没有。所以你不需要任何钱，你所有这些罐子里都有很多钱，霍夫曼说，是的，但是食物罐里什么也没有。
And so that's mental accounting, right? And it used to be like certainly in my grandparents generation that that's literally how people did it, but we still do it mostly in our heads. And it can make us do all kinds of funny things. So one of the things that's happened over the years is that Richard has actually played a psychotherapist for many people who come to him with their economics problems. And I'm actually going to do the same thing here. One of the things I've noticed about myself is that my wife and I, we share our finances. So we have a joint checking account, we sort of draw from the same pool of money.
这就是心理账户，对吧？过去，至少在我祖父母那一代，人们确实就是这样做的，但我们现在主要还是在脑子里这样做。这会让我们做出各种各样有趣的事情。所以这些年来发生的事情之一是，理查德实际上扮演了许多带着经济问题来找他的的人的心理治疗师。我实际上也准备在这里做同样的事情。我注意到自己的一件事是，我和妻子共享财务。所以我们有一个共同的支票账户，我们基本上从同一笔资金池中支取。
But I've noticed that when I go to restaurants, I really like it when my wife pulls out her credit card and pays for the bill now I am effectively still paying for it But it significantly increases my satisfaction with the meal Not to have to pull out my own credit card. Okay, so all right So here's something that would be even better. Yeah. Assuming you and your wife trust one another, I recommend that you each get separate checking accounts.
但我注意到，当我走进餐馆时，我真的很喜欢我妻子拿出她的信用卡的并为账单付钱。现在我实际上仍然在支付它，但这显着增加了我对这顿饭的满意度，因为不必拿出我自己的信用卡。好吧，所以。好吧，这里有一个更好的建议。是的。假设你和你的妻子彼此信任，我建议你们各自开设单独的支票账户。
What? No, you can still have a, my wife and I have this arrangement. So we each have a separate checking account and a joint checking account. And splurges, if I buy myself a new set of golf clubs that I desperately need, or she buys her fourth camera because she travels the world taking pictures, I don't see that. So the splurges come out of your individual checking account. Exactly. And gifts. So if your wife picks up the tab, it will come from her account.
什么？不，你仍然可以有一个，我和我妻子就有这样的安排。所以我们每个人都有一个独立的支票账户和一个共同的支票账户。如果是大手大脚的花销，如果我给自己买了一套我急需的新高尔夫球杆，或者她买了她的第四台相机，因为她环游世界拍照，我不会看到这些。所以大手大脚的花销是从你们个人的支票账户里出的。没错。还有礼物。所以如果你妻子买单，这会从她的账户里扣除。
That's even better. That's really a good idea. And I mean, this is a recipe for a marital harmony. LAUGHTER One of the findings of mental accounting is that people keep tabs in their head about how much money they need to make on an annual basis or a monthly basis, or even sometimes on a daily basis.
那更好。这真是一个好主意。我的意思是，这是婚姻和谐的秘诀。笑声心理账户的发现之一是，人们在脑子里记着他们每年、每月甚至有时每天需要赚多少钱的账单。
And one of the things that you explained to me was this might explain why it's sometimes difficult to catch a cab on a rainy evening. Can you tell us why mental accounting might make it harder for us to catch cabs on rainy evenings? So this is a study that some friends of mine and I did a long time ago in New York. And we were taking a lot of cabs and we were talking to the cab drivers. And we would ask them, how do you decide how long to work? They rent the cab for 12 hours, which is a long time to drive in Manhattan. And then they have to take it back within the 12 hours.
你向我解释的事情之一是，这可以解释为什么在下雨的晚上有时很难叫到出租车。你能告诉我们为什么心理账户可能会让我们在下雨天更难叫到出租车吗？这是我和一些朋友很久以前在纽约做的一项研究。我们当时坐了很多出租车，也和出租车司机交谈。我们会问他们，你们是怎么决定工作多长时间的？他们租出租车12个小时，在曼哈顿开车这可是很长的时间。然后他们必须在12小时内把车还回去。
And a lot of them would say, well, what we do, I set a target. So renting the cab costs me 100 bucks, and then I have to fill the tank up. Let's say that's another 25 bucks. So I want to make a certain amount above that, say $100. And when I hit that, I go home. Now, an implication of that is, on days like rainy days
他们中的许多人会说，好吧，我们的做法是，我设定一个目标。所以租出租车花了我100美元，然后我必须把油箱加满。假设那是另外25美元。所以我想在这个基础上赚取一定的金额，比如100美元。当我达到这个目标时，我就回家了。现在，这意味着，在像下雨天这样的日子里，
where there's lots of demand, they hit their target early, and they go home. Now, what would an econ do? An econ would drive more on the busy days. And on the sunny day, when nobody needs a cab because they're walking, he would go out for a walk himself. Again, if we go back to getting along with your spouse, imagine the guy comes home at two in the afternoon,
需求量很大，他们早早达到了目标，然后就回家了。现在，一个经济人会怎么做？一个经济人在生意忙碌的日子里会开更多时间的车。而在晴天，当没有人需要坐出租车因为他们都在走路时，他自己会出去散步。同样，如果我们回到与配偶相处的话题，想象一下这个人下午两点回到家，
and his wife says, how come you're home so early? And he says, because I didn't make any money. Right? I mean, this is not going to go over well. No, go on. So you've got to go out there and drive around for three more hours, burning gas, not making any money. Right.
他的妻子说，你怎么这么早就回家了？他说，因为我没赚到钱。对吧？我的意思是，这可说不过去。不，继续说。所以你必须出去再开三个小时的车，烧着汽油，却一分钱也没赚到。对吧。
But the interesting thing, of course, is that standard economics would predict that people actually would act rationally, that they would actually work more when the demand is higher, and they would work less when the demand is lower. And of course, what we find is exactly the opposite. Exactly. One of the interesting implications of mental accounting is that where the source of people's money ends up changing how they spend the money.
但有趣的是，标准经济学会预测人们实际上会理性行事，当需求更高时，他们实际上会工作更多，而当需求更低时，他们会工作更少。当然，我们发现的情况却完全相反。完全正确。心理账户的一个有趣的含义是，人们金钱的来源最终会改变他们花钱的方式。
So there was a study by Vivian Azalezer, I believe at Princeton University, looking at prostitutes in Oslo. And what she found is that the sex workers were willing to spend money that they received in the form of welfare checks or other kinds of subsidies on things like rent and important things. But they spent the money that they earned from sex work. They were far more likely to spend that on drugs and alcohol. That the source of the money determines how you actually spend the money.
所以有一项研究由维维安·泽利策进行，我相信是在普林斯顿大学，研究对象是奥斯陆的性工作者。她发现的是，这些性工作者愿意把她们以福利支票或其他形式补贴收到的钱花在房租和重要事情上。但她们把通过性工作赚来的钱花掉。她们更有可能把这些钱花在毒品和酒精上。金钱的来源决定了你实际上是如何花这笔钱的。
I saw a clip from a video, it's called Welcome to Me, starring the comedian, Kristen Wigg, about a woman who suddenly wins a huge amount of money, and I'm gonna play the clip for you, and I want you to talk about this idea, so if we could play the video, please. 14, there's 57, 15, and 54, and 39.
我看到一个视频片段，叫做《欢迎我》，由喜剧演员克里斯汀·韦格主演，讲的是一个突然赢得巨额资金的女人，我要为你播放这个片段，我希望你谈谈这个想法，如果我们能播放视频的话，请放。14，有57、15、54和39。
Thanks for calling the California lottery. If you're calling to report a winning, just say, I'm a winner at any time. I'm a winner at any time. What's your name? My name is Alice Cleague. I want $86 million. You truly want the lottery? Seriously? Can someone Google that? You must won the lottery? Seriously.
感谢拨打加州彩票热线。如果您是来报告中奖的，随时说“我是赢家”。随时说“我是赢家”。你叫什么名字？我叫爱丽丝·克利格。我中了8600万美元。你真的中了彩票？真的吗？有人能谷歌一下吗？你一定中了彩票？真的。
Can someone Google that? You must be the big winner. I am rich. Me too. I want to talk to you with me as the host. I want to talk about crime events. No. OK, step.
有人能谷歌一下吗？你一定是大赢家。我很有钱。我也是。我想和你谈谈，由我来做主持人。我想谈谈犯罪事件。不。好的，停。
Do you want to talk about? Me. How much will that cost? $15 million. Oh, and I want to come in on a swan boat. You're off your meds. You're living in a reservation casino and you're hosting your own talk show.
你想谈什么？我。那要花多少钱？1500万美元。哦，我想乘天鹅船出场。你没吃药吧。你住在度假村赌场里，还主持你自己的脱口秀节目。
It's a new era. $86 million. We go live in five, four, three. What is she doing? I think she's a little frozen. You're on TV now. Hello, I'm Alice Cleague, and welcome to me. So Richard, why is this?
这是一个新时代。8600万美元。我们还有五、四、三秒直播。她在做什么？我觉得她有点呆住了。你现在在电视上了。你好，我是爱丽丝·克利格，欢迎来到我的节目。所以理查德，这是为什么？
Why is it that when we receive money from certain sources, the way we think about spending that money changes dramatically? You know, one of my colleagues, my fellow troublemakers, is David Labeson, who's just become the chairman of the Harvard Economics Department. Used to be one of my protegees. Now, you know, anyway. Some of my friends had a roast for me a couple weeks ago because I had a big birthday.
为什么当我们从某些来源收到钱时，我们考虑花这笔钱的方式会发生巨大的变化？你知道，我的一个同事，我的同伙，是大卫·拉布森，他刚刚成为哈佛大学经济系的主任。曾经是我的门徒之一。现在，你知道，无论如何。几个星期前，我的一些朋友为我举办了一个致敬会，因为我过了一个大生日。
And he was telling the following story. A bunch of us were invited to Washington must have been 15 years ago when David was a struggling young assistant professor and did something for the National Institute of Health. And they gave us a $200 honor a rarium for the day. So I was saying, you know, this is ridiculous. We don't work for $200 a day.
他当时讲了这样一个故事。大约15年前，我们一群人被邀请到华盛顿，当时大卫还是一个苦苦挣扎的年轻助理教授，为美国国立卫生研究院做了一些事情。他们给了我们200美元的出场费作为一天的酬劳。所以我当时说，你知道，这太荒谬了。我们不会为一天200美元工作。
We have to go out and spend this money on dinner. And so we went out and had a good dinner. You could get quite a good dinner for $200, $15 years ago. Now, David was not happy about spending $200 on dinner, and he now claims it was more like $300 when I got done with the wine. But you know, this was my way of thinking, I'm not going to work for $200, but I'm happy to have a good dinner as a result of helping out the NIH. Yeah. So, Sadiya said, found also, for example,
我们必须出去把这笔钱花在晚餐上。所以我们出去吃了一顿好饭。15年前，200美元可以吃上一顿相当不错的晚餐。现在，大卫对花200美元吃晚餐很不高兴，他现在声称当我喝完酒后，费用更接近300美元。但你知道，这就是我的思维方式，我不会为了200美元工作，但我很高兴因为帮助了美国国立卫生研究院而能吃上一顿好晚餐。是的。所以，萨迪亚发现，例如，
that if you want to reward employees at the end of the year, giving them a cash bonus is very different than giving them a vacation. That even though you're giving them the same amount of money, you're giving them, let's say, $500 as the bonus versus $500 as a vacation, people's report being significantly happier when you give them the vacation than when you give them the cash.
如果你想在年底奖励员工，给他们现金奖金与给他们一次度假是非常不同的。尽管你给他们的钱是一样的，比如你给他们500美元的奖金与500美元的度假，但人们报告说，当你给他们度假时，他们明显比你给他们现金时要快乐得多。
Why is that? Well, because if you give them the vacation, they get to go guilt-free. I rediscovered this last week with my daughter and I made a mistake and it's a mistake. I have all the people shouldn't have made, but I made a mistake. And it's a mistake. I have all the people shouldn't have made, but I had good reasons. And I was well-intentioned. So my daughter's a Metz fan. And one of the Metz pictures happens to be a neighbor.
这是为什么？嗯，因为如果你给他们度假，他们可以毫无负罪感地去。我上周通过我女儿重新发现了这一点，我犯了一个错误，这是一个错误。我明明不应该犯这样的错误，但我还是犯了。这是一个错误。我明明不应该犯这样的错误，但我有充分的理由。而且我是出于好意。所以我女儿是纽约大都会队的球迷。大都会队的投手之一碰巧是我们的邻居。
So she was a Metz fan. And I thought it would be nice to buy her two tickets to one of the first round games when her neighbor was pitching. But it was, I got this idea late. So I went online and I found that I could get tickets for about $400. But I didn't have time to buy the tickets and mail them to her. So I sent her an email with a link to this website saying,
所以她是大都会队的球迷。我觉得给她买两张第一轮比赛的票会很不错，当时她的邻居正在投球。但这是，我这个想法产生得太晚了。所以我上网发现我可以买到大约400美元的票。但我没有时间买票并寄给她。所以我给她发了一封电子邮件，里面带有这个网站的链接，上面写着：
okay, it looks like you can get tickets for 400 each. I'm going to send you $1,000 by two tickets on this website. And she had already expressed great excitement about getting to go to this game. So I send her that email, I get back at text. LOL, this is just like one of the examples from your book. If you send me a thousand dollars, I'm not going to spend it on baseball tickets. So now she would have been happy to, had centered the tickets for sure they would have gone to the game, but I send her the $1,000 nothing so I didn't send her the $1,000. More of my conversation with Behavioral Economist Richard Thaler, after this. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantan.
好吧，看起来你可以以每张400美元的价格买到票。我要给你1000美元，在这个网站上买两张票。她之前已经对去观看这场比赛表现出极大的兴奋。所以我把那封邮件发给她，我收到了一个短信。哈哈，这就像你书中的一个例子。如果你给我一000美元，我不会把它花在棒球票上。所以现在她本来会很高兴的，如果我送了她门票，他们肯定会去观看比赛，但我寄给她1000美元却什么都没买到，所以我没有给她寄1000美元。稍后将继续我和行为经济学家理查德·塞勒的对话。这里是隐藏的大脑，我是香卡·维丹塔姆。
Back in the 1970s, Stanford psychologist Walter Michelle conducted a series of experiments that came to be known as the Marshmallow Test. Small children were put in a room and told they could either get one marshmallow right away, but if they stayed in the room and didn't eat the marshmallow, they would get a second. Children who tried not to eat the first marshmallow came up with ways to distract themselves. Watching these children on video is hilarious. All right, here's the deal. Marshmallow for you. You can either wait and I'll give you another one if you wait or you can eat it now. When I come wait and I'll give you another one if you wait or you can eat it now.
早在20世纪70年代，斯坦福大学心理学家沃尔特·米歇尔进行了一系列实验，后来被称为“棉花糖实验”。小孩子们被带到一个房间里，被告知他们可以立即得到一个棉花糖，但如果他们留在房间里不吃掉这个棉花糖，他们就会得到第二个。那些试图不吃第一个棉花糖的孩子想出了各种分散注意力的方法。在视频中观看这些孩子们真是太搞笑了。好吧，交易是这样的。这个棉花糖是给你的。你可以等着，如果你等着我会再给你一个，或者你现在就可以吃掉它。等我回来，我会再给你一个，所以你得待在这里，坐在椅子上直到我回来，好吗？
When I come back, I'll give you another one so then you'll have to stay in here and stay in the chair till I come back okay. I think we should tailor a video of a marshmallow test in progress where a small boy tries desperately not to eat the marshmallow placed in front of him. At one point he leans lovingly into the marshmallow and takes a great big sniff. And then sadly looks away. How'd you do? Did you get it? You did?
我想我们应该剪辑一段正在进行中的棉花糖实验的视频，视频中一个小男孩拼命忍住不吃摆在他面前的棉花糖。有一刻，他深情地向棉花糖倾身，深深地吸了一口气。然后难过地把目光移开。你做得怎么样？你拿到了吗？你拿到了？
You want it, didn't you? Yeah, so that's how you'd give me another one. The excited boy crams both marshmallows, chipmunk style into his mouth. So talk about self-control Richard. Why have classical economics ignored the idea that humans have trouble with self-control? So economic theory says that we optimize and that we always choose what's best for us. So that includes self-control. And so in these experiments, if you'd rather have two marshmallows than one, you should be willing to wait 10 minutes. But as, you know, obviously, kids
你想要它，对吧？是的，这就是你如何会再给我一个。那个兴奋的小男孩把两个棉花糖像花栗鼠一样塞进嘴里。那么谈谈自我控制吧，理查德。为什么古典经济学会忽视人类在自我控制方面存在困难这一观点？所以经济学理论说我们优化，我们总是选择对我们最好的东西。所以这包括自我控制。所以在这些实验中，如果你宁愿要两个棉花糖而不是一个，你应该愿意等待10分钟。但正如，你知道，显然，孩子们
have less self-control than adults. So this experiment kind of exaggerates that. But what you get from those videos, those precious videos, is the real important idea, which is that self-control is work. Resisting temptation is work. This is important, you know, 30% of Americans are obese. Half of Americans are not saving enough for retirement.
比成年人的自控力要差。所以这个实验有点夸大了这一点。但从这些视频中，那些珍贵的视频中，你得到的是真正重要的观点，那就是自我控制是需要努力的。抵制诱惑是需要努力的。这很重要，你知道，30%的美国人肥胖。一半的美国人没有为退休存够钱。
So these are enormous problems that we as a society face, and they are at their core because exerting self-control is difficult. In some of these marshmallow experiments, they used Oreos, and my favorite one of these in one condition, there was a kid and he had three Oreos in front of him, and he could have one condition, there was a kid and he had three Oreos in front of him. And he could have one now, but he was looking at the three.
所以这些是我们作为社会面临的巨大问题，它们的核心原因在于发挥自我控制是困难的。在其中的一些棉花糖实验中，他们使用了奥利奥饼干，我最喜欢的一个条件是，有一个小孩，他面前有三个奥利奥，他可以在一个条件下，有一个小孩，他面前有三个奥利奥。他现在可以吃一个，但他一直在看着那三个。
And what he does is as soon as the person leaves the room, he opens up the Oreos, licks out the middle, and then puts them back together. And I have a deep suspicion. These were done many years ago at Stanford. I'm pretty sure that guy is Bernie Madoff. There's interesting work that you've cited by George Lonestein and others looking at the difference between hot and cold emotional states, which is that if you ask me right now, would you be able to resist having dessert at lunch? I would say, yeah, sure, I can probably resist having dessert at lunch, but an hour
他所做的是，一等那个人离开房间，他就打开奥利奥，舔掉中间的夹心，然后把它们重新合上。我有一种深深的怀疑。这些是多年前在斯坦福大学做的。我很确定那家伙就是伯尼·麦道夫。你引用的乔治·洛温斯坦和其他人的有趣研究着眼于热情绪状态和冷情绪状态之间的区别，也就是说，如果你现在问我，你能在午餐时抵制吃甜点吗？我会说，是的，当然，我可能能抵制在午餐时吃甜点，但一个半小时
and a half from now, when I'm really hungry and I'm sitting down at the table and there's dessert in front of me, the person whom I am at that point is very different than the person I am right now. Right. So, you know, we can all relate to that. We all know the hazards of going to the grocery store hungry. And let's say you're there on Thursday and you missed lunch and it's six o'clock. And you're buying dinner not just for tonight, but also for Saturday. Now, your hunger now should not affect the size of the roast you buy for Saturday, but you'll buy a bigger roast.
之后，当我真的很饿，坐在桌子前，面前有甜点时，我那个时候的那个人与我现在的这个人有很大不同。对吧。所以，你知道，我们都能对此感同身受。我们都知道饿着肚子去杂货店的危险。假设你在周四去那里，你错过了午餐，现在是六点钟。你买晚餐不仅是为了今晚，也是为了周你现在的饥饿感不应该影响你为周六买的烤肉的大小，但你最终会买一块更大的烤肉。
The other thing, of course, we often do sometimes when we have problems with self-control, is that we try and have an external enforcer. We try and appoint somebody who will help us run that kind of self-control. This of course goes back to the old idea, the myth of Ulysses who was sailing by the sirens. He was afraid that he was going to drift close to the sirens. And so Ulysses had his men bind him to the mast of his ship so that they would be able to sail close to the sirens. And here the sirens song without actually being to sail close to the sirens and hear the sirens song without
当然，另一件我们经常做的事情是，有时当我们遇到自控力问题时，我们会试图找一个外部执行者。我们试图指定某人来帮助我们进行这种自我控制。这当然可以追溯到古老的观点，尤利西斯的雷神神话，他当时正航行经过塞壬海妖。他担心自己会漂流得离塞壬太近。所以尤利西斯让他的手下把他绑在船的桅杆上，以便他们能够航行到靠近塞壬的地方，并听到塞壬的歌声，而实际上并没有去靠近塞壬并听到塞壬的歌声，同时
actually being tempted to go toward the sirens. So people have tried variations of this and all kinds of things to try and address are the temptations that we expect to face in the future. I came by a very nice clip from the TV show Curb Your Enthusiasm where Larry David is essentially asked to be the enforcer for one of his friends. Take a look at the clip. So, you hungry? Storing.
实际上没有被诱惑走向塞壬。所以人们尝试了这种方法的变体以及各种各样的方法，试图解决我们预计在未来会面临的诱惑。我偶然看到来自电视剧《抑制热情》的一个非常不错的片段，拉里·戴维基本上被要求成为他朋友的自我控制执行者。看看这个片段。那么，你饿吗？存储。
Good, we got a great meal. And some fabulous desserts. Which, by the way, I need you to keep me away from no matter what. Oh, OK. Yeah? Because I put a lot of time into this. I need like a dessert referee. All right, I'm your guy.
很好，我们有一顿丰盛的大餐。还有一些美味的甜点。顺便说一句，不管怎样，我需要你阻止我靠近它们。哦，好吧。是吗？因为我在这个上面花了很多时间。我需要一个甜点裁判。好吧，我就是你要找的人。
You promise? Yeah, I promise. OK, I'm counting on you. All right. Ah. Ah. No, no, no, no. I'm just going to have a bite. Oh, no, Okay, I'm counting. All right. Ha-ha-ha. No, no, no, no. I'm just going to have a bite.
你保证？是的，我保证。好吧，我指望你了。好的。啊。啊。不，不，不，不。我只是吃一口。哦，不，好吧，我数着呢。好吧。哈哈哈哈。不，不，不，不。我只是吃一口。
Oh, no, no, no, no, no. Just a bite, come on. You know what? You told me specifically not to let you have any dessert. I appreciate it, Larry, but I changed my mind. Yes, yes, yes. But you said no matter what. But you know what?
哦，不，不，不，不，不。就一口，来吧。你知道吗？你明确告诉过我不准吃任何甜点。我很感激，拉里，但我改变主意了。是的，是的，是的。但你说了不管怎样。但你知道吗？
I'm changing it. And this is now I'm saying, thank you for helping me. I'm going to have some cake. No, no, but you can't change it. That's why you say no matter what. But you know what, I'm changing it, and this is now I'm saying thank you for helping me. I'm gonna have some care. No, no, but you can't change it. That's why you say no matter what. This is the what. But now what? That's why you asked me and not these other people
我在改变它。而现在我说的是，谢谢你的帮助。我要吃点蛋糕。不，不，但你不能改变。这就是为什么你说不管怎样。但你知道吗，我在改变它，而现在我说谢谢你的帮助。我要吃点蛋糕。不，不，但你不能改变。这就是为什么你说不管怎样。这就是那个“不管怎样”。但现在又怎么样？这就是你找我而不是其他人的原因
because you knew I wouldn't let you. Why would it? Larry, you told me that it's not a real deal. Oh, yeah. I asked you, I asked you, I asked you, I asked you, I asked you, I said no matter what. Oh, yeah. Oh, no.
因为你知道我不会让你吃的。为什么会？拉里，你告诉我这不是一笔真正的交易。哦，是的。我问过你，我问过你，我问过你，我问过你，我问过你，我说不管怎样。哦，是的。哦，不。
No, no. No. No. Oh, no. Oh, no. Oh, no. Oh, no. Oh, no. Oh, no. Oh, no. Oh, no.
不，不。不。不。哦，不。哦，不。哦，不。哦，不。哦，不。哦，不。哦，不。哦，不。
Oh, no. Oh, no. Oh, no. Oh, no. Oh, no. Oh, no. Oh, no. Oh, no.
哦，不。哦，不。哦，不。哦，不。哦，不。哦，不。哦，不。哦，不。
Oh, no. Oh, no. Oh, no. Oh, no. Oh, no. Oh, no. Oh, no. Oh she was staring the dessert in the face, you know, let me add it. Thank you all so much and thanks Richard Taylor.
哦，不。哦，不。哦，不。哦，不。哦，不。哦，不。哦，不。哦，她正面对着甜点，你知道，让我吃一口吧。非常感谢大家，也谢谢理查德·泰勒。
APPLAUSE That was Behavioral Economist Richard Taylor. His latest book is called Misbehaving, the Making of Behavioral Economics. This week's show was produced by Karamagar Galeson, Maggie Pennman, and Max Nestrak. Our team includes Tara Boyle, Raina Cohen, Parts Shah, Jennifer Schmidt, and Renee Clar. Our Ronsang heroes this week are Adam Osman, Nikki Strickland, Thomas Bussey, and Don Gooden. are Adam Osman, Nikki Strickland, Thomas Bussey, and Don Gooden. Adam, Nikki, Thomas, and Don work on our facilities team here at NPR, and they recently helped
掌声那是行为经济学家理查德·泰勒。他的最新著作是《错误行为：行为经济学的形成》。本周的节目由卡拉马加·加勒森、玛吉·佩恩曼和马克斯·内斯特拉克制作。我们的团队包括塔拉·博伊尔、雷娜·科恩、帕茨·沙、詹妮弗·施密特和雷妮·克拉克。我们本周的无名英雄是亚当·奥斯曼、尼基·斯特里克兰、托马斯·布西和唐·古登。亚当、尼基、托马斯和唐在我们NPR的设施团队工作，他们最近帮助
us move to a new floor of the building. They intuitively understood how important a good work space is to be creative and productive. They put in long hours, including on the weekend, and helped us pack, unpack, and get settled in our new space. I'm so grateful for their hard work. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们搬到了大楼的新楼层。他们直观地理解了良好的工作空间对富有创意和生产力的重要性。他们工作了很长时间，包括周末，并帮助我们打包、拆包并在新空间安顿下来。我非常感谢他们的辛勤工作。这集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来留下评论。